mire china se ha beneficiado del
petróleo ruso durante la Guerra en
Ucrania y mientras que occidente
sanciona ve oportunidades podría decirse
que fue un error de los aliados
occidentales no calcular que podrían
fortalecer a los orientales
yo creo que no hubo un seguimiento
suficientemente
consistente con respecto a cómo
evoluciona la relación Rusia China desde
principios del siglo a partir de la
firma del tratado de amistad entre los
dos países que ha ido profundizándose en
términos de de una convergencia
estratégica que muchas veces los hace
asumir posiciones similares en el ámbito
internacional pero también que funciona
como un elemento de complementariedad
desde el punto de vista económico y
político en el ámbito de Brasil
Bueno ahora en esta reunión del día de
hoy Putin hablaba de nuevas fronteras A
qué se refiere cuando Utiliza este
término en las relaciones y por qué no
hizo parte de Esta visita que además
podría interpretarse Incluso como
provocadora cuando estamos en la semana
del aniversario de la Guerra de Ucrania
bueno primero que la visita en Pink ya
había sido anunciada por el presidente
Putin Hace unos días y de alguna manera
se preveía y presupongo que eso es lo
que está sucediendo la visita de wangie
es para preparar justamente la visita de
chillipín que en algún momento pero esto
depende desde luego de cómo evolucione
la situación geopolítica internacional y
los Beijing decidirá en función de eso
si la visita debe hacerse en un momento
determinado a Moscú Lo cierto es que
banji también afirmó en esta gira
europea previa llegáramos q con mucha
Claridad que los los lazos entre Rusia y
China son más sólidos que nunca Y esta
es la frase exacta que utilizó y
finalmente Le quiero preguntar si puede
Rusia con ayuda de China mantenerse a
flote y respaldada pese a las sanciones
Y si podría china considerar un apoyo
frontal a Putin en la Guerra de Ucrania
yo creo que esta este entramado
euroasiático que han de alguna manera
desarrollado entre China y Rusia con la
participación de otros países en torno a
una serie de organismos como la
organización de cooperación de Shangai
la unión económica de euroasiática y la
misma iniciativa de la franja y de la
ruta
todo esto constituye un tejido
institucional muy importante liderado
fundamentalmente por Rusia y por China y
por lo tanto se complementan y convergen
desde el punto de vista estratégico como
decía al principio en el ámbito
euroasiático protegiéndolo de la una
posible cualquier interferencia
occidental Entonces en ese sentido desde
luego la convergencia entre las dos
naciones es cada vez mayor y ha estado
funcionando muy bien A pesar de que hay
divergencias también y diferencias en
algunos planos y desde ese punto de
vista Tenemos que tener en cuenta que si
bien no ha habido Esto no es una alianza
militar de ninguna manera Hay toda una
serie de tratados pero ninguno implica
un componente militar Lo cierto es que
hace una semana han estado desarrollando
una vez más ejercicios navales conjuntos
con otro miembro de los brics que es
Sudáfrica y esto muestra que desde luego
se está se está desarrollando una forma
muy aceitada de funcionar entre las
fuerzas armadas de ambos países esto no
significa que China de alguna manera
decida
romper con esa línea roja que le ha
planteado occidente de enviar armas no
sabemos yo no tengo evidencia respecto
por lo menos hasta el momento